nous sommes dans une des artères les
plus passantes de strasbourg les
touristes doivent donc la parcourir
est ce qu'il s'arrête monsieur dans
votre librairie pour acheter un livre
sûrement mais vous savez il ya touristes
et touristes au des livres à proprement
parler nous les casser des guides et
plein de la région de la ville se fait
mais faut-il en conclure hâtivement que
le touriste que l'homme en vacances ne
lit-on ainsi certainement mais où il a
fait sa provision guy rocher sont livrés
avant de partir et puis ici à proprement
parler ne l'achète pas de livre dans une
ville où il passe vers son journal
éventuellement ou un niveau des poches
très petite vente plan guide interprète
est ce que la clientèle allemande
achètent des ouvrages en france
maintenant est ce qui nous étonne
toujours ce qu'ils achètent des dix
vraiment ici celle des livres allemand
en france étaient livre allemand en
france ou est ce qui leur arrive
également de s'intéresser sur un plan
touristique à l'histoire de l'alsace
même sur toute la profession général
s'intéresse d'abord aux buts bleus et
ensuite
demande d une bâche sur l'alsace par
exemple l'art en alsace bout encore
d'autres ouvrages plus spécialisés
est-ce qu il arrive également que tu une
clientèle de passage s'adresse à vous
afin de vous demander des livres qui ont
une certaine cote mais qu'il considère
comme livre de vacances certainement
à cette époque de l'année
la production est quasi morte on peut
dire on vit sur les lauriers mais il
n'en reste pas moins que des ouvrages
tel que daninos ou encore les ouvrages
en général sur le mourre bon énormément
de succès et puis a aussi planté des
tentes
initiée actuellement c'est très peu
l'idée l'idée précise parce que les
maisons d'édition tourne au ralenti et
les titres chocs sont sorte de plus tôt
en automne vous même quête libraire
lisez vous en vacances c'est à dire on
lit en fait très peu le libraire lis
beaucoup moins qu'on pouvait s'imaginer
une faillite il y aurait trop à lille
oui mesdames je crois une maman jeudi le
plus et c'est assez normal dire est ce
parce qu'il paraît tellement de choses
alors j'ai en vacances de train de faire
un tri et de lire les choses qui
m'intéressent personnellement pourquoi
est ce qu'il vous arrive tout de même de
recevoir des clients qui n'ont pas
d'idée préconçue et qui sont en vacances
qui souhaiteraient mieux connaître
l'alsace par exemple ah oui ça très
certainement effet arrivé sur toute
l'alsace sur le plan touristique offre
quand même énormément d'intérêt alors il
ya le problème des asiatiques le livre
sur strasbourg le livre avec des photos
le livre souvenir ça c'est également une
vente que nous faisons aux touristes
actuellement
est ce que le livre avec photo à
l'engouement du public de préférence un
autre moins illustré sur le plan du
diois souvenir très certainement sur le
plan du livre pur non le livre avec
photo c'est typiquement le livre
touristique pas exception en dehors du
temps des vacances
peut-on dire qu'ici en alsace on lit
beaucoup
oui
je crois que c'est une des villes froch
strasbourg est connue pour être une
ville aux activités culturelles assez
assez poussées et du fait même olibeau
selon adam et en général les gens ces
styles dire viens je crois qu'il ya une
infime minorité de gens fuient servier
dans une catégorie très événements les
acheteurs de livres de poche bon marché
ce père bibliothèque ses responsables
sur les grandes équipes rentrent
également les gens qui ont une
une période où un dada une étude
approfondie qui font parfois pour leur
plaisir personnel
sur les lignes puis les autres à chaque
des best-sellers
je vois jeu politique aussi parfois
on peut appeler ça savoir lire
réellement s'intéresseront pas un besoin
et sentir est-ce qu'il arrive en
fonction de ce que vous venez de me dire
elle qui arrive parfois que vous soyez
déçu par votre métier de libraire
et bien non vie si on laisse faire un
jour et puis il ya autre chose qui vient
est alors comment ça c'est très bien moi
je voudrais exprimer un désir ouailles
et oui je tenterai dans une librairie
pouvoir feuilleter des ouvrages achetés
ou ne rien acheter mais en tout cas
sentir un accord avec ledit problème est
assez la librairie idéal je crois qu'ils
rentrent aussi alors une question de
modernisation la librairie une question
de pratique dans une île vanille comme
celle ci je crois que vous auriez vous
pouvez le faire très très volontiers ces
mêmes mensuel et profond mais il ya
pratiquement vous aurez du mal à tirer
les livres seraient pas où le projet il
ya quelqu'un dira pardon monsieur qui
nous marchons à un peu sur le bio pas
vrai ça vous en dira et vous partirez
relativement vie a maintenant tenir une
conversation évidemment